today's episode is brought to you by
liquid death
you know it's good
what's up guys i want to let you know uh
that i will be touring in
st louis we've added a show cincinnati
charlotte durham we've added a show
chattanooga knoxville wilmington wilkes
bar
minneapolis charleston richmond
baltimore albany we've added a show
buffalo new york
and columbus ohio columbus we will be
adding a show if we haven't
already theovan.com tour the only place
to get tickets
all other sites uh they're going to jack
up the prices so
go to the links through theovan.com tour
and thank you
uh for supporting me and my dream
recently i've undergone a ketamine
therapy
and i wanted to speak with someone
who is an expert in that field and uh to
learn more about
my experience and learn more about the
therapy
overall uh today's guest is the founder
and the medical director at the
chattanooga ketamine center
it is dr jason pooler
[Music]
[Applause]
dr jason pooler thanks for being in here
today man
thank you i appreciate it and so you're
you're a doctor of well
i'm a i'm an md so okay i'm a physician
um and i'm and a physician is what just
a doctor
uh a medical doctor like you go to four
years of medical school after college
and uh okay that's sort of
like dr dre that's not enough it's
like the um in the united states you
know the md is sort of the
what people think of when they think of
physician those are you know that's
the standard process you go to medical
school okay then you usually do a
residency
to sort of sub specialize into a
different area of training
okay and then you go to work
and so these days you're working in the
ketamine how did you get working in the
ketamine therapy and like where are you
at with it right now like
are you actually practicing it are you
running a practice that provides um
the therapy to people so both
okay i was it's kind of one of those um
long routes to get back to where you
started
and i i originally trained
as a general surgeon a long time ago
and then i went into anesthesia and i
did that for about a decade
and ketamine therapy
sort of became um
more studied as a result of its use in
anesthesia and because it's an
anesthesia medication
but it had some interesting side effects
that they they looked at over time that
they couldn't explain
and that research is what has brought us
to
ketamine therapy today in the use of
treatment resistant um depression and
other you know mental health problems
what exactly is it used to treat the
therapy
so you can use it to treat a lot of
different things it depends on
what you're doing with it the way it is
used
most often is to help people who have
had
a lot of problems with depression who
have failed
a lot of other therapeutic approaches
and so
so what ketamine offers is a new tool
to help people who are
still suffering tremendously kind of
springboard
back onto the road of life and and
um it is it's really interesting
that the way it works it doesn't work
like normal antidepressant medicines it
has nothing in common with them
um the way it's almost a new technology
then i guess in approaching
treating depression so the the easiest
way to describe it is
why they started studying it to begin
with okay and that was back
almost 20 years ago oh dang they
they realized that when they gave
ketamine to patients getting operations
they required less narcotic pain
medicine
during the operation in the hospital and
after the hospital stay
then than other patients they said why
is this just doesn't you know
why are they having less pain they had
no explanation
so they they looked at it and what they
discovered was that what it does
is it changes your perception of pain
so you can see something that you've
experienced
as less painful hence
you don't need as much medication to
cover your pain i see so you're not
feeling as much pain because you're
not seeing it you're not seeing the seed
of whatever it was as as
painful so therefore like the growth of
the pain isn't as severe
at that time uh the way the best way i
like describe it to people is yeah i
have two daughters and
and say we go get flu shots and one
daughter gets a flu shot and she's like
ow
and my other daughter she gets a flu
shot and she's like and her response is
much more
okay we know that the the shot
is the same but the response is
different
so one is perceiving something with more
distress than the other
and the way ketamine works is it helps
your pain sort of shift from that
that more visceral response to a more
that hurt but i'm okay response okay
it's a persp like it's like changing the
lens on how you see pain
so that you can see things and you can
kind of look at them from a distance and
sort of
go around things that have happened to
you and you can kind of connect to
yourself
from those places and it's a it's
it's it's not spiritual but it's not far
from it
right do you feel like it gives you like
a look at yourself like you kind of
see yourself whereas a lot of us have a
tough time
seeing ourselves because we're in
ourselves you know exactly
yes 100 because it's like if you're on
the
playing field you can't really see
what's going on and it sort of puts you
up in the stands
of your life that's interesting and you
have a lot of places in your past
or a lot of patients that have come to
me is you know you're living your life
and life's hard and people get hurt
and depending on where they are in their
life they sort of package that up
and they put it away because they don't
want to feel that anymore
but it doesn't really go away and so
those those let's call them firewalls
um they're no-go places in your brain
but they're still sort of resonating
through your existence
so they're shaping typically your
relationships
and your career right and that's like
that
that uh what is that movie um
kung fu panda you know oh i was thinking
of uh
master oogway in his uh um
we often find our destiny by trying to
avoid it
oh yeah interesting yeah i was thinking
of that movie where that boat gets stuck
in boston i'm talking about where they
go fishing you know what i'm talking
about
and there's all the storms perfect snow
oh yeah oh yeah yeah
that didn't have a good ending though um
yeah it didn't
but um so i see what you're saying so
yeah it kind of gives you an experience
to step outside yourself
so were you able to see that whenever
you was working in anesthesia were you
able to see
people having that experience like were
you able to visually
see that or were you not able to grasp
kind of the concept of it
of of exactly that until i'm guessing
later which we haven't discussed yet
until you got into actually
experiencing uh using ketamine
when i was when i was practicing
anesthesia um
i used to do that hitman anesthesia guys
that hit man that rolls in there
that's the guy a lot of people some
people don't even need they'll be like
they just want the anesthesia some
people
i have a buddy who's addicted to um
he was addicted to uh inoculations and
he's breaking into walgreens and doing
all the damn uh
whatever it is the covenant in the
[ __ ] i don't know his cove is before
this so he was just doing flu shots you
know
but that's you know people get people
get
people get into certain things you know
but um anyway i don't know how i told
you that exactly but um
what i'm trying to tell you right now is
just that okay so yeah so
were you able to see stuff whenever you
were working in as an anesthesiologist
were you able to see some of that or was
it more like
that you got a a stronger idea to work
with ketamine
like and understand it later on what i
noticed was
that when we used it and we didn't use
it a lot
i mean you just give them it as part of
anesthesia they did better
so everything seemed to work better they
just sort of
seemed more functional they had
what we saw was they just they they felt
better they they
came out of it better they they got up
they got around
and um and that was sort of how the ball
got rolling on why is this happening
and then you know then they started
figuring out that hey this is
actually doing something in the brain
for real not
just some accident and
then they started experimenting not
experimenting but they started you know
using it in a more of a clinical sense
for people who are really struggling
because before ketamine really the only
thing that they had
was um ect you know putting electricity
through your head
right and i have taken care of a lot of
patients with that and they did not like
that
and i can see why so what did you ever
have to do that to people
i did actually um not not even familiar
with that
yeah i i did it when i was an anesthesia
uh
resident um about a decade ago they'd
they'd bring us a bunch of patients from
the
uh psychiatric hospital and they'd line
them up and
we put them to sleep and this
psychiatrist would
shock their heads and we were like
wide-eyed and like is this real
and i guess it helped
so you would put them to sleep first
yeah just very
briefly so you just with uh like
propofol or something okay so you just
you would just make them unconscious
just for a few minutes and i remember
this
this the psychiatrist she had like this
head of hair that was like
huge and it was like gray and kind of
like uh back to the future style yeah
and uh
and she would she would put these probes
on this guy
on these guys heads and like this is in
and you know we're
kids and we're just like okay
wow and zap them decently oh yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah because we had to
paralyze them because when you
when you shocked them they'd be like and
what was supposed to be happening
so my understanding is kind of bootleg
you know my understanding is it actually
helps a lot of people but it is not
readily accessible so we were doing this
in a hospital in a recovery room with an
anesthesia team
in sort of the critical care area of the
hospital so that's not something that is
accessible to 99 of the population right
any given day and and so that's sort of
the problem
so so this electro convulsive therapy
this uh in which small electric currents
are passed through the brain
triggering a brief seizure changes in
the brain chemistry quickly reverse
symptoms of certain mental health
conditions
so this was this was almost
this was kind of like a ketamine this is
ketamine's kind of like that
no okay no that um this is what they
were doing early on this was the only
alternative okay so you go to provide
what
uh relief from depression okay i see
what you're saying
because they still have a therapy i have
friends that go and get electrocuted a
little bit every day
yeah yeah so so that is sort of like the
um oh yeah there's a good one see that
guy right there
on the left oh yeah oh yeah he's going
deep yeah that's what they did
he's got a candle in his mouth that
dudes that's that's so when he bites
down from the electricity he doesn't
break his teeth
oh my god yeah right
you know wow so it's hard that's
frankenstein it's hard to get a lot of
people to sign up for that because
i mean you google it and you see that
and you're like no i'll pass
yeah they're grilling that brother up
man unfortunately that's pretty heavy it
seems like to me
um so so how so how did they evolve out
of this so this isn't really practiced
readily anymore it wasn't easy you said
there was you had to have a lot of
people on site to do it
so ect um is still used
in limited form today the the problem
with it is it's a pretty big deal to do
and so you don't have doctors offices
doing ect
these are special circumstances usually
with patients who have profound problems
usually patients who are in uh inpatient
psychiatric hospitals
these are not people who are out walking
trying to hold jobs
so this is a different level
different level you know people who come
and seek care for depression
they they you know get talked to by
their doctor or their provider and they
get
you know put on a medication or
something and they they go to a
therapist and they try and work through
that
and usually at some point um
some people sort of hit the wall with
that um not everybody but
a lot of people are hitting the wall
with it and what they do is with ect
uh no with just just going to um some
almost no one gets referred for ect yeah
that's i mean because that seems like
yeah so you're saying that's more like
in psych wards and stuff like that like
bottom of the barrel really
they're trying to jump start i mean that
looks like the damn lord's jumper cable
there it is it's it's it literally is
it's like you're trying to jump off the
brain
wow trying to get it hit to fire again
yeah and so that's like people who are
like
you know in in hospitals mostly
people who are not holding down jobs
people are not having
relationships because they can't okay
right
so so so the rest of people who are
struggling
you know they go to their doctor they
get put on antidepressants they go to a
lot of therapy
right that's me that's been me i'm an
example of that yeah yeah and so
so you're you're sort of chugging along
and and
you're existing but you're not really
you know if you look at like the road of
life
you want to be on the middle of it and
you want to be
comfortably cruising down it you know
and these are the people who
they're like on the shoulder or they
fall off into this they go often on the
side of their shoulder and they
they have a hard time pulling themselves
back up and it's because they're
the the medicines they help
but they don't necessarily get people to
a place of
well-being that they're seeking you know
there's there's
existing and then there's like really
living
right yeah i think i can definitely test
testament to that
yeah i kind of feel like like i don't
understand
one of the reasons i went to get the
ketamine therapy is because i didn't
know why i'm still on antidepressants
it's like one of the weirdest medicines
that
you know i was having a tough time when
i was like 20 and i went in
they put it on they put me on it or i
agreed to be on it you know i mean i
took part in it and
and then now 20 years later i'm still on
it so it's kind of like
like if you broke your leg you wouldn't
have a cast on forever probably so some
of that to me is like how what's going
on here like is this something i need to
be on forever
so that's one of the reasons that i went
in probably to check it out you know
and you know it's the the work
that is being done in this is is
amazing i mean there are
some very smart people who sort of
helped shape this
sort of treatment path and
the way i i look at it um
is i i look at people who come to me and
they have all these symptoms they're
either
depressed they're anxious they can't
sleep
um they're they have like attention
problems they
they zone out because they can't zone in
um
then you have people who are like trying
to kill themselves
or they're addicted to things and what
it really is is
somewhere within them they have a lot of
pain okay they have a lot of distress
something is is primarily wrong
and that is not going away with the
antidepressants they're just more like a
band-aid
to it they're covering the symptom as
opposed to addressing the symptom
right so the driver is usually
pain that is from somewhere in that
person's past
that they have not been able to truly
grieve over
and feel like sort of reconnected to
themselves
and and as you probably
experienced to some degree when you went
into the ketamine room
you could see your pain you could see
around in yourself and you could kind of
go places those
those firewalls you could kind of look
in places that you couldn't look in
before
because you had the capacity to you were
sort of protected by the ketamine so you
could
look around corners in your mind and see
oh yeah
that's there you know i wish i'd had a
better i was in there with a therapist
and i i think they were just more of
like there if
i had an issue um i sometimes wish that
somebody would have been like prodding
me more
or telling me how to it's almost like
when you go snorkeling that's what it
kind of felt like a little bit
it was like i'm looking at
a lot was going on you know if i felt
like i'm a roller coaster i'm on a
roller coaster i felt like
the world is kind i felt like i was on
space mountain sometimes with my eyes
closed you know just kind of like moving
through like
did you have the round shapes or the
square shapes
i mean i i mean i think there was a turf
war going on because there was a lot of
there was some real i think it was a lot
of shapes out there you know it was
definitely like somebody was
um i mean i remember one time literally
yelling out that i was a cryptocurrency
i thought i was
like i went it got pretty gnarly you
know like it got pretty gnarly like i
remember one time thinking
there's no way i'm gonna end up back in
my chair in this therapist office i
don't know how
i'm going to get there from where i am
yeah i
i had some fun you know so that kind of
stuff was kind of exciting and i think
sometimes i got too
caught looking at the the the experience
and not using the experience right so
that's why i wish that
there had been more before i went in to
get it that i had had more of an
understanding of
how to navigate the universe a little
bit and how to use the experience
yeah um because that i that i didn't
have
that that's sort of a um so we're
learning as we go
right and so what and this this is
relatively recent um ketamine assisted
psychotherapy so what is it
and and that's exactly what we're
talking about is we know ketamine helps
we know it works
do we know exactly how it works people
are debating it because
you have competing interests you have
competing ideologies
but we know that people feel better
now what we want to try and do is make
that a more durable
state not you come in and get your
ketamine you feel good for a couple days
and then you
you come back a month later and you get
more ketamine because
that's going to present a societal
problem in time if you're if you're
always on ketamine
you know we've kind of done the opiate
thing so that that's one thing that
that is we don't want to do because you
have some places that are like giving
you to go home with
and that is sort of like
um you can do a lot more with
ketamine assisted psychotherapy you can
use that place you're in
to visit the pain
that has brought you to this distressed
state
yeah there was a moment i remember there
was a moment where i got to see my dad
be around my dad right
and i'd never my dad died when i was
like 16 and he was really older man
he was 86 when he passed away and i was
16. so he was older when i was born he
was an adult you know
he was senior citizen but um
i got to have like this experience
around him and it was like a real
like it felt like i was around him and i
got to let him
i i got to you know i felt like my dad
never knew how much i loved him i felt
like i had just never gotten to an
age where i could tell him that i loved
him you know
and i didn't realize how much that was
kind of haunting me i think somewhere
inside of me
you know like um exactly i just never
knew like that that was such a big thing
going on underneath me somewhere
and uh and i literally got to have
a moment or a little bit a couple
moments with him in a
emotional state kind of it felt like
anyway to me it felt very real to me
that i was letting him know
uh how much i loved him yeah
and that and that's priceless because
there's no there was no other way to do
that i mean
there may there may have been but i i
hadn't found that yet
yeah that that is like
core to what um
ketamine is psychotherapy gives people
access to it's like those little gaps
those little holes in our heart
that that happen to us when we're young
shape
a lot of our life and so to be able to
reach back in time
and and find yourself then and there and
that
that sort of that grief pain
of separation that you you didn't get to
have with him
you could connect to yourself and and
sort of complete
almost in a way like the grieving
process so you could release
that tension from yourself yeah that
that distress that's
that's like that's in there and it's
always in there and it's
you don't know how to get it out and
you're pushing through life and a couple
decades go by
and you're like i'm still haunted by
things and some people
are not able to even see some of those
things
because i've taken care of people i'm
not taking care of some pretty funny
people
you know like i have
trees on my in my room where i do it and
they're like sitting there and they're
you know they're giggling and then you
know they're like oh that tree just got
up and ran out of here and i'm like
okay and but then some of them
start singing for me and then some
people start like trying to do yoga
poses in their chair
and i'm like i'm like you can't quite do
that right now
right and they you know
no i mean it gets a little wild well i
remember even being a child i remember
getting something was wrong with my
penis when i was young and they had to
like
like i had like a small urine hole or
whatever i mean i could pee probably
11 feet you know what i'm saying like i
could really pee
and it was people were like oh he's
magic and stuff people you know small
town people think you're
you know with a rival church or
something you know all kind of [ __ ] but
um so anyway yeah they said they had to
cut the whole larger on my
uretha i think it's good urethra so
i remember we went in and they put my
anesthesia and when i came out
i asked where all the big black women
are at
and i remember the doctor telling my mom
that like
we thought it was just the craziest
thing and my mom had said that
before when i was even younger i'd had a
surgery and i had a laura a big black
nurse was my nerve was the nurse
so i wonder if maybe there was just some
moment that was like stuck in my head
like through those little
kind of deals but um but anyway i i
i don't know why i went off on this
tangent but um
i guess i just wanted to know like yeah
i guess is there
what's happening during the experience
when somebody gets the ketamine what's
happening
so the way the way i do it is
i i put a iv in them so i can like turn
it up and turn it down so you can slow
down if they start getting overwhelmed
okay because sometimes people you can
and you can just see it you know
uh they're like because it's like
there's lots coming at them
and and i'm sitting there and you
they tend to start having like their
blood pressure their heart rate go up
because they're getting like they're
seeing stuff and
okay so you want to kind of try to
minimize that you want to make it
constructive yet um
sufficient to like have the experience
it can't be so low that you're like i
didn't feel anything
right but you don't want to like you
know
ruin them i mean not ruin them but you
don't want to make it so overwhelming
it's no longer
useful right i see what you're saying
yes so you want to kind of have a find a
balance
and um yeah that's what the one i did
the place that i went they they
they did it and then they kind of just
was a low dose until they kind of
got to you to a level where they could
where it seemed like it was manageable
and effective i guess to communicate
with the therapist yeah because
what what i do is you know the way the
research was done is you do six
six infusions and i like to have them
come in and i
don't usually have somebody start
ketamine right away i usually want to
talk to them because i want to know like
their life narrative to some degree and
then you kind of get an idea where
where the boundaries are like you can
tell like
i go through this thing where i'm like
okay how was um
you know where'd you live where'd you
move how was that place how was this
place
uh how was first grade how was second
grade and you keep going through it
and things start popping up pretty fast
and people don't realize what's in their
head and then they're like
oh yeah i forgot about that and
but you can kind of tell this is not in
ketamine this is just sort of getting to
know them
because you got to know what are you
going to do with the ketamine experience
so i want to have like a road map
right and and then as we do this
the first couple of sessions you want to
get there they're sort of like get
everything
chugging you just want to get them into
a better state of well-being so that
their capacity
to examine some of these long-standing
things
is um available to them okay you don't
want them to
not be able to to sort of explore this
um you want them to be in fight good
enough fighting shape
that they're like i can do this um and
we go through it and i've had people who
couldn't remember entire years of their
lives
these are smart very successful people
who who have been it's like something's
been wrong their whole life
and and you start going through it with
them
and it keeps going back further and
further and further and sort of like the
the beginning of the flick of the wrist
on that little
thread of pain and and a lot of times
these little firewalls conceal it
and then they have their ahas and they
remember more and more and more and i'm
not telling them what to remember
i'm just listening and so what are
examples of some things right and what
are some examples of
so so well what are some examples of
things that people could remember kind
of
if you can share and that you have to be
specific to that person obviously right
um so i had a patient who um
had a series of moves that were sort of
stressful on on him as a child
and um it's
one of them after one of the moves um he
was
um very seriously disciplined by his
uh by his dad um to such a degree that
that it um he didn't remember it until
we sort of toggled the switches around
it
and we started sort of gently like how
is this location he was like
that was warm that was nice how was this
location where you moved to
i didn't like it how was this house you
lived in
in this place i don't remember how was
this house i remember not being happy so
already we're pointing to
narrowing it narrowing it yeah and he
didn't remember in the ketamine session
and then later that night he did
and so then we came back around the next
time and we talked about
it and we sort of work into the and
you know i i approach this with i guess
the right word is
like a great deal of reverence you know
these people are sharing with me
their emotional pain and i'm helping or
trying to help them
connect to themselves so they can feel
whole because all this
all this distress that people have in a
way
it's like incomplete grieving yeah
and people can't cry that much and so
they
they suck it away and and what the
ketamine does is
it allows you an opportunity to kind of
go back in places
that you can't do awake you just can't
yeah and i've seen that i've seen
patients i start talking and i'm you can
tell they're like
they don't want to talk about it you
know i had a lady
who who i took care of who um
i was the first person she told in 40
years that she was raped in high school
and she's you know she's in her 60s
and her life has been tough
and you know so her life has been shaped
by fear
right yeah i'm sure fear
um probably feeling like she couldn't
tell people things shame
and it shaped her relationship so she
was in you know
not the best relationships because she
was
put in the state by this experience that
had shaped her ability to interact with
life
right and here we are 40 years later and
she's a wonderful lady
and and i'm it's that's why i mean it's
like i feel
i i i approach it with a great deal i
think the right word is reverence
because it's it's not sad but it is
it is like a a very important meaningful
and and tender thing to do um yeah 100
man yeah i feel sometimes like i'm
trying to make
rope out of like the tattered
the very frayed pieces of like
of my youth kind of right as i get older
you know um and not very afraid
i don't wanna i'm not trying to have any
self-pity or something but i feel like
that that's what you try to as you
as you get older you're just still
trying to make this rope or make a knot
out of this
uh make different knots out of rope that
was kind of like
ram shackly kind of tied to the
beginning of the foundation
at certain points yeah the underpinnings
of of wellness start early
yeah and and usually um
attachment feeling you know attachment
injury is
is no joke so most children
and what i mean most say 99.999 percent
of kids
are loved by their parents okay but what
happens is
parents can show
this much love and
the child actually needs more love than
than they get and it's not that there's
a malicious thing it's just there's a
mismatch
right and that that mismatch creates
this like this
emptiness the start of loss or grief or
or not being cared for
and depending on how it gets nudged in
life it starts showing up as
you know how they choose you know
relationships how they
try to navigate life and and if it's
really bad and they start
having other things pop up and and they
get on medicine and it
works or it doesn't you know medicines
do work so let's
let's not say they don't work but right
but they don't work
great debt can often feel like an uphill
battle
if you're carrying a credit card balance
and you keep chipping at that little
daddy
and you keep chip chopping at it but you
can't really get a big chunk
you only chip chopping and not chunking
well upstart can help you
upstart is the easiest and fastest way
to pay off your debt
with a personal loan all online whether
it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses
over half a million people have used
upstart to get a simple
fixed monthly payment find out how
upstart
can lower your monthly payments today
when you go to upstart.com
theo that's upstart.com
t-h-e-o don't forget to use our url
to let them know that we sent you you're
tired of the debt you're tired of that
packaged uh
that you know that uncomfortable payment
get it right
get it light loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com
theo and see if they can help time to
tighten up and that's mack weldon
mack weldon will tighten you up if you
like to get a man in your pants that's
mack weldon
premium men's essentials brand that
believes in smart designs i wear mac
welding
underpants and i haven't tried any
other accoutrements or body you know
cloth body fixtures but i really i
thoroughly enjoy their underpants
they hold me and make me feel good and
that's
mac welding from socks shirts hoodies
underwear
polos and active shorts mac weldon
promises comfort
and consistent fit
that's right macweldon has created a
totally free loyalty program
level one gets you free shipping for
life once you reach level two by
spending two hundred dollars mack weldon
gives you twenty percent off
every order for the next year trust me
you will want mack weldon
throughout your body it's great product
i enjoy to have it on right now
for twenty percent off your first order
and to support the podcast
visit macweldon.com
theo and enter promo code theo that's
m-a-c-k-w-e-l-d-o-n
dot com slash theo that's right twenty
percent of your first order
macweldon.com theo inner promo code theo
yeah i notice i i start to notice that
the behaviors that i feel like affected
me when i was young
are behaviors that i now exhibit you
know and ones that i like
imitate you know towards others that
kind of keep me in a in a place
that is comfortable even though it's not
the best place that i want to be in a
lot of times
you know the devil you know yeah it's
interesting man
um so with the
when people go under the under the the
solution under the
ketamine therapy right right so i
remember like
i mean i remember
like i would
yeah i wish i'd had i think when i went
met with the therapist we started the
same day that i went
so i do wish that i'd had a little bit
more of a breath of communication with
them
so i'd have probably had just so that
there was a better so that we're like
okay these are five points that we want
to try and
attack you know or or meander around or
things you know
yeah um because sometimes i felt like
not that i was wasting my time but that
i was wasting the experience
and i may not have been it could just be
me being judgmental but
um because i think it was helpful but
there were times where i felt like
like i was just kind of swimming through
some of the same waters without really
knowing what we were looking for trying
to do that that's sort of
the um but that may be okay maybe that's
just what you do sometimes with it well
and that's why you know this is on
ongoing
um evolution and care because ketamine
assisted psychotherapy
really hasn't existed very long because
you're right people were like okay what
are we doing with it
and then as we started to you know
explore what we could do with it we
realized that hey
we can do a lot more than we thought
when did it start
ketamine assisted psychotherapy yeah or
even just ketamine assist like when did
ketamine start i mean everybody always
calls it a horse track all the time you
know well ketamine was originally i
think it was
invented in what 50s or 60s
and it is it's an anesthesia medicine so
horse tranquilizer anesthesia
it's it is an it's a dissociative
anesthetic by definition
okay okay so you use it to put help put
people to sleep for operations or
procedures and is it found in nature no
it's not no it's me
um no not that we know of it could be
out there do you think it could be or no
probably not um but yeah there are other
things that are sort of like
um in 62 by professor
it was tested on animals which provided
promising results it was used for
testing on human prisoners in 64.
there you go i didn't know that
proof tax faster and reduce toxic
behavior which made it the preferable
anesthetic choice over pcp damn
it's interesting it's amazing how many
drugs used to be just avail
like i remember i was working on um i
was working in mississippi on a farm for
a while and the man
said that they used to buy ecstasy at
the bar
they had it like in a jar on the bar and
you could go buy it you could buy a tab
of ecstasy like before it was
i guess illegalized you know like there
was a brief time where it was a legal
drug you could buy they
you know prior to like i think it was
the lsd and all that psychedelic
research was
was actually going really strong and
what happened was i think
the government finally said enough
because it started to begin
it was recreating too much that was when
you had sort of like the hippies and lsd
and all that
stuff and oh yeah and so when they shut
it down they
they they shut down all the research too
so it clobbered the
the ability to investigate all these
kind of interesting substances
for real clinical aid you know use
roll the ball forward you know 20 30
years and now
now you actually have like um the
government is
is um very interested in in some of
these therapies and and the
real reason is the state of
veteran health um you know they're
you have so many veterans that are
struggling
yeah and you know they have these these
organizations that are trying to
reach out to veterans but the suicide
rate among veterans is
really horrible wow i don't even know
that yeah
i i saw a metric a while ago it was like
more combat veterans from afghanistan
have killed themselves than have died in
uh the line of fire
wow so so you think about the they're
that distressed
and then they come back here and they
just you know go back to
work and it doesn't work that way yeah
and so
the you know the government's funding
research on this stuff because
they got to figure out how to help
people it's yeah it'll help save them
money too if they cannot
it is not to put it right there but also
yes it is but it's actually providing
the
the the gas for helping actual therapies
that work as opposed to just
um throwing dollar bills at things yeah
so that's
you know i'll take it you know if we can
help get serious about it
yeah for sure um and so
so those are types of people so can
people really use this therapy to get
off of
antidepressants and how does that work
short answer is don't know um
what what i have seen in
and like i said this is sort of on the
fly like this is
this whole body of knowledge has grown a
lot is
is people who have
um profound distressors in their life
that are
under addressed are going to have
probably pressure to have
symptoms so they're going to be in
depressed states and if you can help
people
through something like ketamine assisted
psychotherapy resolve
those long-standing pains of emotion in
them
then it stands to reason that the odds
of them finding a way
forward are better
that makes sense yeah it's sort of a
wishy-washy statement but
it's it's the same thing it's like like
you know at my place
we sort of break down why people are
depressed and it's and you sort of break
them into these categories
um where you have your your your groups
it's more like um
serotonin and then you have your
dopamine people so i actually asked my
patients i'm like what gets you high
i'm like uh what's booze do for you or
uh what's
cocaine do for you and uh and or
shopping or gambling or because you're
trying to
stratify them like what what what's
goosing them
right right right so that helps you pick
like your therapy
because if you got a guy who can't stand
cocaine or stimulants like that
then it's probably he's probably needs
more serotonin
so you can sort of shape what you do for
them to help them with that
and you you can mix it so it's all
becoming like this basket
of ketamine sits alongside
um a lot of other tools and if you're
using all of them
together and you're helping this person
who comes to you unpack
what they're carrying and you give them
better tools in their pack to go on
then the odds of them staying in on the
road are
better right and that's sort of like how
like
integrative psychiatry works now it's
you don't just say hey here's your
prescription get out of my face you
actually sit down you talk to him and
find out
why they're suffering yeah not oh you
have depression
it's like okay where what
what's your you know what's wrong what
hurts
when did it get started right how has it
shaped you
can you talk about it and what level of
detail can you talk about it
and that's why i mean it's it's a very
like
almost it's a very
intimate conversation yeah you know
that's a great that's a great word
intimate i feel
it felt really intimate you know i
remember
i mean right when i started to go under
i just started tears just like rolled
out of my eyes you know
like i don't even know what was going on
really you know i think it could have
just been
like i mean me i'm always probably 30
sad so who knows what it was you know
but
um but i remember just being pretty
emotional out of the gate
and the first day i was dehydrated
literally just from like crying i think
half of the whole session like
and some of it i didn't realize i was
crying like i didn't even really feel it
because i was kind of also
you get kind of you're kind of
anesthetized in a way
so the main part of me that's still
awake is kind of this kind of that
all-knowing place inside of your head
where you have ideas and stuff you know
yeah like whenever you're thinking about
something you envision something like
that place you know
i i have had quite a few patients that
and i tell them this i'm like hey you
know
they a lot of them tend to feel pretty
quiet like they have like um
all the the the mental movie is sort of
taking a break when they're when they're
done for their session for the day and
they kind of like
like yeah just roll with that don't do
any homework just sort of like
try to you know i try to keep them on
zero um
and i and i say it is you know very
possible that if you just start burst
out into tears later tonight
that's normal yeah that means like
you're you've connected to something
and that's like an overdue release and
so
i remember i was talking to this this
young lady
and she was um she was upset she was
like what am i crying i can't stop
crying it's like
i was like you're going to hate me for
saying this but this is very good
yeah because she was just releasing all
this things that
she had packed up in her and
and the next day she kind of like you
know it's like after a good cry you like
but she cried you know a big chunk of
her life
out in the night and yeah yeah that's
that's a great way to say it i think it
felt like that like just a lot of stuff
that was going on
you kind of got to like take the
pressure valve off a little bit yeah
in some ways um but yeah i would like to
have another experience with it in the
future and be able to
know going in have more of a game plan
going in so that i can
but then one of my issues sometimes is
controlling things
so it's interesting so i don't want to
go in sometimes to that and try to
manipulation you know
so which might not even be possible
under that um
it kind of depends on your mindset on it
you know i think
what i try to do is i try to give people
a lot of
sort of neutralizing information so that
they understand
exactly what's you know the more you
understand what's going on and why we're
doing this they sort of their their
their guard starts to come down because
really
if you don't want it to work it's not
going to work and
and so you want them to be like okay i
understand why this is going to happen
and so one of the best things i like to
do
actually is find out what they can do
with it so i do this thing where i give
my patients a it's a it's like a
butcher paper it's you know it comes off
a ream but it's actually graph paper and
i haven't put it up on the wall and
we do these five columns and it's your
age down the middle and then
where you lived what your relationships
were what your activities were and what
your substances were
and you just sort of write it down from
zero to
today and if they can do that
then you can kind of get a they can sort
of look at their life
and if they can't do that it sort of
shows me where we need to
sort of use ketamine to examine some
things that are
like sort of like their no-go zones and
i got a number of guys who they can't
finish it because it's sort of like
you can't finish it and if you can't
finish it then you know i
you know i don't know how we're gonna
finish it in
this context without it being
emotionally brutal on you
right and that's what the ketamine
allows is it takes the edge off
looking at things that you can't look at
oh wow
yeah it was interesting like i wonder if
there were things where maybe my
my being or whatever was just afraid to
uh
to unwind them right or just couldn't
you know or couldn't find like
the key the way into them sometimes it's
so it's such a
small opening into getting into like an
old feeling
in an old way i see that pop up all the
time yeah it's pretty fascinating we got
a question that came in right here from
a young gentleman right here that seemed
like a decent guy right here
what up i got a question for dr pooler
and for theo
so i wanted to start off uh dr pooler
what is
the negative connotations with the
ketamine therapy and then what would be
your argument against that
um theo what was your favorite thing
about ketamine therapy versus regular
therapy
gang gang hang about um that's a good
question what you got doctor
um so the the negative connotations i
i think the the societal thing is
there's sort of a societal sort of
frown against like psychedelics in
general and
you know it got started back probably
with like the hippies and lsd and so
you kind of get this blanket oh this is
that
psychedelic hippie trippy stuff and and
so
it can marginalize its actual utility
right as a a real medical therapy and
there's an organization
um called maps that that is dedicated to
doing
high quality research to counter balance
that notion that this is like you know
step into my van
type stuff and yeah and uh and to make
it legitimate
in the proper studies and the proper
funding from
you know like the dod and things like
that because they want it to be as
legitimate as possible um
yeah it's interesting almost you really
have to mod like there has to be a group
kind of monitoring that branding and how
that really
how it hits the public and stuff like
it's a little wild westy right now
yeah they've even said it in some of the
publications because
the you know all the ketamine right now
it's it's
technically off label the way the way
everybody's using it not a lot of
medicines get used off label all the
time
so um is that a problem no but
but it it needs to be
looked at down the road because you know
it's like the saturn life skits in the
80s where you know you go to your doctor
and you get a
hey doc i got a i got a i got a you know
my pinky hurts oh here's a prescription
for some weed
you know remember those skits that that
were like that and it's like you gotta
you gotta be careful you don't have the
slippery slope because i get
i get um mailings from places they wanna
ship me um like ketamine lozenges and
stuff and
damn that's that's not gonna
that's not gonna go well yeah i don't i
i i had six
infusions like you're talking about like
you like you mentioned is probably the
pro
product probably protocol not protocol
but that's the best
no it's the best that's the research
that's the research
um that is what they fared it out in the
research was
the most legitimate and best way to
proceed is
is what you did and after four i felt
good after four
the last two i felt a little it got a
little griswaldy you know i felt like i
was on a
you know it felt like i was just on a
kind of a gnarly vacation
you know it's like i don't really know
if i needed the last two or
maybe i did i don't know i just i think
at that point i started to think
i wish i had a better game plan going
into this so i could use it to the best
of my ability
i didn't know if i was using it to the
best of my ability the therapist was
saying um
and it was a great it was a great place
and everything but he was saying that it
work it'll work kind of no matter what
there is is there some truth to that
that it'll work no matter what
yes um so we know it works okay the
question is is how long does it work
right and and what the um sort of like
the
industry the professional side of this
industry is trying to do
is make this a a
very serious one-time attempt
to get as much utility out of it
so that that the effect is very durable
and that's why you got to do all the
side work with it and that's why you
want
really really good assisted
psychotherapy because you can sort of
unwind
things that are still sort of in the
background if you're
if you're sort of poking around and the
more things you can resolve
the more your heart can be at rest
um the odds of you needing more of it
are less
and that's very desirable so you know
like
at my place um
i've only had one patient ever
need a booster and he was a he's a
veteran
and his there's some you know there's
some confounders with that but
but most people are are and i i don't
let them go either i don't like
when they come to me i i take them on
and and
we get to know them on the front end and
we're following them on the back end and
i'm taking care of all their other
sort of issues i don't i don't like send
them to places to
you know you you come to me and i work
with you and the idea is that
we're here to get you into a better
place of durable well-being we're not
here to
give you ketamine right it's not you're
not like a sawmill you're doing
actual boarding kind of you're actually
bringing them on
um what is the number one thing that a
lot of uh
veterans struggle with or what is what
is the
so some of that trauma you always hear
about the ptsd there's two things
actually
and it's actually interesting the way
this is starting to pop up
um so ptsd and actually uh
concussions so traumatic brain injuries
if you take a
somebody who has been uh in combat and
has had
ordinance exploding around them and
they've been taking those shock waves to
their head even though they look
fine it's has a pretty serious
depressive effect right and it's it i i
talked to a guy out in
colorado last week about this they're
they're trying to find ways to heal
these guys
because they tend to be like very
sensitive to
emotional dysregulation because you
think about you take a fish bowl
and you put you cook up like 30 30 bags
of ramen okay
okay and you put it in a fish bowl like
like a goldfish bowl
so it's like completely full of noodles
right okay say that's your brain
and then you hit it with a bat the
noodles are going to move
so if you're taking concussions
repeatedly it's going to
scramble your noodle yeah and so those
are nerve connections that
that are responsible for your daily
function and as those get ripped apart
and
try to heal they don't necessarily get
it right all the time and so
like people are they're they're
they're hurt in a way that's hard to
address
interesting yeah because it doesn't seem
like we're meant to be batted around
that much you know
no not at all um so those are some of
the most common things you see
as far as veterans is like uh stuff from
concussion stuff
that's that's one okay the other one is
is frankly
the the grossness of war i mean yeah
you see two of your buddies incinerated
in front of you and that gets on a
record that won't come out of your head
and and that's all they can see so then
they get like super um
super sensitized so so
they're stuck in this place in their
mind where they're still driving down
that road when that car bomb went off
and so when they hear a door slam or
something that that's a neural circuit
that got
burned in in the strongest of ways so
they have this they have this nerve
pathway that that's just
seared into you and so it's on alert
because it's still there and so
your neighbor boom closes the door
you're like and
or you hit the deck or you do those kind
of things and so
that's one of the things that you know
they're proposing
um that they use ketamine to work with
you know patients on why does trauma
create such strong like neuropathways or
like connection does that make sense
the and does it it sounds like it must
right it does because
um so it's it's post
traumatic stress what what happens is
when something happens to you you form
a temporary memory okay like what'd you
eat for dinner last night you could
probably tell me what it is
um salad but but two years from now two
years ago what'd you eat for dinner
i have no idea yeah i don't know so
intense experiences
make different signals like right but i
could tell you if i was in like a boat
accident
correct now ramp that up
to about 11. and
and where andrea galen yeah then it gets
pretty deep and then then you can't
forget about it because it's
it's it's it's sort of your your
neurochemistry
has decided that this needs to be a
permanent reminder
probably from a more for safety probably
yeah more of a
like fight flight or flea type thing and
so
given where we are in the world today so
it's inflammation kind of then
yeah so those are yeah because
that's the craziest thing about it is is
the way the immune system works with
your mind
is is phenomenal like
you can even measure it now like you
know how when you get the flu
you um you feel crummy you don't want to
get off the couch
food doesn't taste good sex isn't
interesting all that stuff goes away
right
imagine being like that walking around
living life like that
that happens because your immune system
knocks out your dopamine system
so you don't have access to your
dopamine system because you're sick
because of your immune system because
you're supposed to be healing under a
tree
but if you're walking around and you
have your immune system activated
you begin to look like somebody who
doesn't have access to the feel good
wait explain that to me again sorry i
got lost so so
your immune system when you're sick
takes your your dopamine system offline
oh that's is what it does that's what it
does that on purpose so you can heal
oh because they don't want you trying to
feel good because you're not going to
heal correct
right got it but if you're walking
around interesting if you're walking
around
day in and day out year in year out and
your your immune system is
slightly activated and your dopamine
system is
always offline then life is flat
and feeling good is inaccessible to you
ah
and are you depressed or you just not
have access to your dopamine system
wow that's interesting yeah that's a
great question and you can check that
with um
it's actually pretty straightforward to
check now you got to get
a simple lab drawn to see if your immune
system is activated
and that helps point therapy so like
what i do is
when people come to me like i check some
labs on them i get to know them a little
bit
in in ways that i do my thing and so i
kind of want to know where they're at
amen so we can start shaping what comes
next
and that's before we take them in the
room because i look at it as i want
i want this to be as useful as possible
right and then
so that when we get to the other side of
it we still are learning things but
like i had a patient who he was done
okay but something else popped up in his
mind because he was having this problem
where
on a regular basis he would have panic
attacks at a certain time of day
okay like clockwork and i i talked to
him i was like
what time of day did your dad get home
when you were a kid and he just stopped
same time of day all his life wow
that's crazy but he was able to see it
then because before he couldn't even see
it
yeah but now we could talk about it and
resolve it and so he was able to see it
when he was under this
the therapy after afterwards so we were
done this popped up even later
because he was saying you know i'm doing
pretty good but i still have this one
thing that's popping up on me and i said
well what is it we talked about it and i
i asked him and he's like
yeah yeah
what um what could you give a question
that came up sean sorry let's get to
that
oh actually this is a comedian friend of
mine shane moss
who he is a psychonaut
so he's like a man who he's very funny
man
and he also is a man who has
experimented with different
psychedelics and stuff over the years to
have experiences just like an astronaut
would with like outer space right
he's kind of done it with like inner
space so awesome to uh have this from
him
theo shane moss here in case you can't
recognize me
i hear you're getting ketamine treatment
i think that's
fantastic very very worth exploring
see if it suits you psychedelics are
not always the most linear thing in the
world compared to other
medications or drugs or what have you
but mental health isn't a linear
thing either and so i wish you the best
of luck i hope it uh
it shows some improvements thanks man um
and my question for your guest is i'm
wondering if you could talk a little bit
about experiential versus chemical
change
rather than taking say antidepressant
every day and
and altering your chemical imbalance or
whatever a psychedelic journey is
a lot more about using that temporary
uh chemical chemically induced
change to have more kind of personal
breakthroughs and
insights and those insights are kind of
what
leads to the personal growth uh
more than some permanent chemical
change that you're doing or a long-term
change that you're doing to your mind
oh yeah yeah thanks brother
so this is like a two-headed
animal here because you have like the
the neurochemistry of what happens okay
and then from there you have what you
experience
as a result of the neurochemistry and
and he's he's
he hit the nail on the head with that is
is
therapy like this allows you to have so
you're getting therapy you're getting
mood elevation from either therapist or
from like a medication you're on
regularly
yeah well you have this thing where it's
a called a
uh a rapid gain so
you're cruising along and also you have
something that goes way up you're like
oh man i figured that out
and and it goes like that but it doesn't
work like that you actually have to go
for a long time and you don't have those
very often
with therapy okay right so what what
ketamine does in psychedelics is
it's like a lot of access to rapid
insight for a prolonged period of time
relative to say going to therapy for
five years
right and it could be a couple hour a
couple minute
actual portal is that what you mean kind
of like that well that's where you talk
about
what happens is we know that ketamine
helps nerves grow so
if you have nerves that are firing in a
way that is
causing you to have a depressed mood
state or
anxiety and you
basically soak those in ketamine for a
say a period of a couple weeks with six
infusions
you can
get some plasticity in how those nerves
work so you can change how those nerves
are connected
they grow a little bit they actually
like they've seen it on the under
microscopes these nerves actually grow
little sprouts and they
they can change and so you're enhancing
your ability to change
at a at like a microscopic level amen
and that
translates into like a change in
perspective on things
yeah sort of metaphysically i mean this
is kind of like we're getting
going into the into the the realm
between
electron microscopy and spirituality you
know what i mean
but but it it is so so if you look at it
how a person experiences it is that they
can see
what they've experienced they can find
things
that they've experienced and connect to
themselves more fully
and if they can be a more full person
and have less
pain carried in them because they were
able to have an emotional release
by connecting to a loss from the past
and they're probably going to walk away
from it feeling better about
life globally yeah you know i think
that's a good summation a little bit of
just what i felt
i felt like there were
new ways to connect yeah
kind of and i couldn't describe it
exactly
and i couldn't manage it
but i felt like
it was helpful i felt like when that
when i
knew more tricks and how to almost use
the controller better i would go back
and play the game again if that makes
any sense it does
um so what's so what's uh
shane is saying is that so you're saying
that so ketamine is more of like an
experiential type of thing
it's both so so to to the person
who's experiencing it they're they're
gaining
um sort of a
they're gaining like this
alternate or this this additional view
of things
they're they're gaining insight they're
like they're up here
and they can look around themselves more
like like not
like they're not in the game sort of
like they're looking at
the game and from that they can be like
you know that really that doesn't hurt
as much as i thought
and they can see like oh i can see that
yeah i never really got over that
that's been sort of haunting me and like
okay
i'm okay and and so
that's what it can provide now the nice
nudge is when you can have somebody like
say
well you remember you mentioned this and
let's let's explore this a little bit
and see how
those decisions sort of were pushed by
emotional distress or pain and rolled
the ball through this event
and then you kind of so you try and
sequence it through
through life so you don't want to miss
things right
it's the gaps the gaps are the key yeah
i could see that yeah i wish i yeah in
hindsight i would go with like a
timeline kind of a little bit of like
a plan i like i like doing the school
thing like yeah
the great you know the one question i
like to ask people is
when was the last time you felt whole
jesus and then what was it that
began to separate you from that feeling
yeah i don't even know man i i probably
was a damn
and a zygote yeah and then and then you
go back to if they can't
if they can't dial it back that far you
go back to like when they were like five
four three when did they feel love two
one blast blast-off is when i probably
felt it maybe i don't even know
yeah i don't know i don't i mean i know
you're not asking me but it's just yeah
it's interesting for people to think
that
the place i was at the therapist hadn't
done the experience does that matter if
they've done it or not um
i i don't know um maybe it doesn't
it's kind of one of those things it
depends on on where the therapist is
what um what made you care about this
how did you get into this whole
universe you know i did anesthesia for
quite some time and
i and you're a real doctor then yeah
yeah i have an md um and um
i saw a ketamine work pretty well and
because i was
i did anesthesia right was it fond being
anesthesia
it was interesting it was fun and it was
crazy
and it was but it was a you know i mean
you listen to music and stuff where you
go in there nothing like that
you know we had a actually we had a
surgeon who who would get noise
complaints from the other ors
because he would listen to death metal
all day and he would turn it up all the
way
and so he sort of had like a his own
little crew because
you kind of have to be like the right be
in the right mindscape to go in there
and listen to
mega death for 12 hours yeah at you know
80 db all day long yeah that's crazy
you're cracking up in a rib cage
and you're hot all hopped up the
surgeon's next door in the room's next
door would complain
you know it's like been in a hotel
they'd be like dude tell them to knock
it off
but it was i mean it was it was it was
crazy
i mean it was good but it was it was
like
super busy super high intensity yeah um
and you have to stay the whole time you
just hit them with that dose and you
roll out
it depends okay but the way our model
was we had
uh nurse anesthetists and
and so we would we worked together with
them and they would stay the whole time
and i would i would come in and
troubleshoot things and get the
get the ball rolling and and you know we
were at a place where we
we took care of really sick people so it
was um
you know it was but you sort of
acclimate to it and then you look around
and you look at what you acclimated to
and uh but but for me what what got me
turned into the corner of this is is um
sort of my understanding of suffering
has evolved a lot
and um
i had a brother and he died last year
he was injured as a child
terribly and
he never could get the help he needed
and so he he
did a lot of drugs he tried to take his
own life several times oh man
it's hard to hear that he did all these
things and and i was sitting there
and and he knew he was dying he was in
hospice
but i was you know looking at what was
coming down the pipeline i was like you
know if
if we can help people who've been
traumatized
like it's sort of like for me it's like
if this would have been around 20 years
ago maybe i'd still have a brother ah
because he he was sexually abused as a
kid
and did never tell anybody nobody
the only reason we found out about it is
because our
our pastor was imprisoned after the fact
by somebody else
dang and so i couldn't figure out what
was wrong with him his whole life
and i i asked him one night and he goes
yep and i was like [ __ ]
and but the damage was just
like yeah how much that shaped somebody
that's young that's
man that's heartbreaking i'm sorry yeah
so
and i'm sorry for him i'm sorry that you
know it's heartbreaking to see you know
i've been
you know a lot of my family and being in
recovery and struggling through those
you know struggling through trauma and
stuff like that childhood trauma not
like that
uh but different types of trauma and
stuff has been pretty prevalent in my
family and
it's heartbreaking to see the effect
that it has on people you know
it it was you know the last six months
of his life i i finally got him to say
because he was like he was a he was a
crusty guy
was he yeah yeah and uh the last were
you guys pretty close
yeah oh that's cool and he knew he was
he knew he was dying
was he drinking himself to death yeah he
did he had the operations and and
he kind of stopped actually but the
problem was is the damage was done and
and but like you know one of the last
times we
we spoke um i was sitting with him in
the hospital he was on hospice and
and for the last six months of his life
i got him to tell me that
i told him i loved him every day and he
was like i love you too
and like just for him to be able to
express emotion was priceless
yeah and then you know one of the last
moments we spoke i said i love you and
he said i love you i love you too and
then he goes and he flips me the bird
and i was like that's
that's mike and uh and so it was like
you know i
he knew at least he was loved yeah and
and um that was in um it's important
yeah i think a lot of people's life if
they struggle with trauma i think some
of it is just yeah
thinking that people don't care people
that think it's unable to feel love it's
weird how a traumatic event can block
off other things you know
yeah he couldn't he he didn't have the
capacity
and he never so he he was
stuck and he could never get out of it
and you kind of wonder
or hope that if somebody else comes to
me
and a little younger and hasn't burned
themselves
physically like like damaged themselves
enough that you can help them turn the
corner
yeah and get healing going in a way that
they they can get back on the road of
life and
and that's sort of that's
to me is a very rewarding way to
interacting with life you know i can
look over my shoulder and be like
i am okay with what i'm doing i'm
helping people
find peace right
yeah it's it man it's so fascinating how
like if you ca if you don't feel loved
or if something makes you feel so
unloved or so damaged that then you it's
very hard to feel love after that
because i think there's just receptors
in you that just do not trust it
or just do not trust the world almost in
a weird way
and i don't even think you can access it
sometimes
like that's the that's the such hard
thing is to be able to
access why or what or how to change it
to get the clay in your hands
you know it feels like you just
can't find it you know um so it's
fascinating to hear that there's
opportunities that this could be a way
where people can
i'm i'm you believe it i believe it i do
i really do because um
i've seen it work i've seen it work on a
lot of people
and it it's one of those things where
it's it's like you get to see these
people come to you and they're just
broken
and and the first time you hear them
laugh
and or smile and you're just like it
it's
it it's i'm in the right place yeah
that's fascinating man yeah i noticed
after a couple of treatments i'd had an
idea i was running
one day and i just had like a good idea
and these have good ideas all the time
i mean i'm just i'm judging my own ideas
but i thought they were pretty good but
but i used to have ideas a lot
and i just for like a year i just hadn't
even gotten an idea
like i've just been kind of living with
the pieces of every day you know
and it's been fine life has been fine
i'm not i'm not complaining i'm not
asking for any pity i'm just explaining
where i'm at but
but i hadn't found it got anything new
to come out of my brain
you know and so i noticed that i was
running by some turkeys somewhere at
this park and then
i don't know i just got like an idea
that was like fun and it made me laugh
it made me smile i was like oh man what
a gift like
when something's able to just kind of
travel through us and make us feel good
which is how we probably should be a lot
of times you know yeah is to be a
conduit for
joy to at least pass through right
instead of being kind of a um
a place where something has put up a
fence or something is put up like a
firewall or
you know different elements like you're
saying yeah um
[Music]
what are the what are what are some of
the side effects that we honestly do not
know about because just to be very
honest and transparent with
um people who are considering this
treatment so there's
there's there are limitations like their
actual limitations like
you can't really have problems with like
psychotic type problems or schizophrenic
type problems it doesn't see that
it it's like it doesn't work that
wouldn't be cool yeah no and if you have
a if you have problems with seizures
you really gotta look into that because
it used to be that ketamine was an
automatic no if you have a seizure
disorder
um and and depending on what's going on
with that they're looking into it
um but um the other things is like
sometimes what you get is is uh patients
actually um vomit and
and it happens and i can almost see it
coming now
it's almost like a the physical need to
expel
bad ah interesting so so like i've taken
a couple patients very recently and
they were super overwhelmed like way
overwhelmed
crushingly and and
and they they just started vomiting and
i knew it was going to happen and
it wasn't a problem but they didn't
understand it i was like yep
it's like you needed to get it out wow
it was like it was like a metaphysical
expulsion of badness from them oh yeah
and um and so that it doesn't happen
very often though
i can see that i could really see that
sometimes
i think all types of things like that
are a mole or something somebody with a
mole and say that's a bad somebody you
know
that's a bad idea or something you had
or that's a something you know that's
something bad that happened to you
you know or sometimes you see like
someone like i'll feel sometimes like
when i'm really going through therapy
and it's going pretty good i'll get
pretty close to this feeling like
there's something in my throat that i
never was able to say or like to talk
about when i was young
yeah or i was afraid to talk and so i
can almost
feel the mass whatever it's not you know
it's all
probably in my head but it feels very
real so those connections from your
you know your your core yeah emotional
centers are
they're they're reaching out into
everything and
you know if you think about a nerve
connection think of like a thread of
hair
from an experience to somewhere else in
your brain it's still there
it's just how how often it lights up and
and it starts pushing on things and
and that's you know like post-traumatic
stress is the hair is the size of my
you know pinky yeah and so it's it's got
domain over your
operating system so to speak yeah and um
what's the question that came in for uh
you have another question that came in
sean
i know we have one from a young uh yeah
let's play this fella right here
the uh what is going on my brother i
just got a question for
dr ketamine as he's in the house um this
is sam from
sydney here and you know down in sydney
we we're team ketamine down here you
know we got that special k
on deck i would say um but my question
for the doc
is is this an addictive substance and
are there will there be lasting effects
from this kind of therapy
um because i can tell you from second
hand
right now i got some friends that could
argue there are some
a little more long-term effects from
this substance and it could be quite
addictive um
some fellas getting banged out out there
in australia
gang brother cheers man yeah what are
some of those what are some of the
effects so
it is addictive um it is not
that addictive but i have talked to
somebody who was
completely addicted to ketamine wow now
the
problem with ketamine is
is it's unclear but this is what the
best
sort of notion on what's going to happen
to people is if you're always
taking a substance that causes neural
growth and neural change
well keep that ball rolling and see what
happens to your mind
so so if you're always changing it and
you're always growing it your
ability to be you is going to
be called into question if you're always
abusing it it's not like you know
opiates you can take opiates for 20
years
and come out of it and still be
your person ketamine is
putting like putting your brain in a
grow box
and you're trying to grow all these new
sprouts and all these new connections so
that you can
connect in a healthier way to to
traverse injuries from the past okay
now we know this is happening at the
microscopic level physically
so if you keep doing that all day long
for years
where's what's going to end up remember
that that bowl of ramen
you keep putting more ramen in there i
don't know what's going to happen but
i can probably reasonably predict that
these people are not going to be the
same
wow and not in a good way that's why
again
you know the the research was a set of
infusions
in order to traverse something that is
essentially beleaguering you in a way
that's preventing you from having access
to wellness
um long-term dosing of it
i at a at a lower level i'm not
sure if that is gonna
[Music]
i i don't do it you don't prescribe it
no i don't because i
i have seen a lot of things and
i want it to be done in front of me i
want the like like
the chap from earlier you want the event
to be very meaningful
you want the sequence of events to be
very
um enlightening and very
meaningful and connecting to yourself
emotionally you want you want those six
sessions to be sort of like a time
of of introspection and healing that's
been
brought to an immensely higher level
because you're seeing ketamine a lot
you i don't want that to be wasted so i
want to do it right
from beginning from before beginning to
afterwards
but i don't want to be picking up that
tool very regularly because
because i don't want to use that as the
crutch
because we we've done that crutch with
other substances in the past and
it hasn't worked out so well yeah it
gets bad it gets
and then people also have to make their
own choices but if there's some
addictive nature to it then yeah it can
be tricky
um and that's what i want to say like
i'm not telling anybody to go get this
therapy or
saying that this is you know i wanted to
have an experience with it
um because i'm going to try to get off
of antidepressants
so i'm working with my doctor now and
try and like
slowly wean myself off which is some
which is cool the the place that i went
the
there they have like some follow through
there with like trying to help me like
do that and
and manage that so i'm excited about
that and i'm still working with my
regular therapist
um but yeah i definitely wanted to have
the experience just so i knew
kind of what it was like and what's
possible
um you know i love to kind of figure out
how i'm thinking and feeling and why and
stuff like that
you know so
it's it's nice to kind of see if what
things i can get get through and get
away from and
i i find that like anchors i can pull up
kind of i find that you know
in in my practice about half of my
patients don't get ketamine
like we we you know it's sort of like
why are you here and they're more
like they don't know why they're there
they're like they want access to
well-being they want relief from
distress
that's what they really want right but
they come in with like diagnoses and i'm
like
well let's talk about what you what's
really going on
and then you know we we talk and we we
gotta you know it's like we gotta get to
know each other it's not like i'm like
hey yeah here get out
um and they may turn into ketamine
patients once we find like hard stops
places that are you know
like i shared earlier i had that lady
she wasn't a ketamine patient okay
and as we got to know each other and i
was sort of helping shaper therapy
using other things we she felt
comfortable sharing me
with some pretty disturbing stuff and
then she shared
some even more to start and then she she
couldn't she stopped
i was like um
yeah it's sort of like let's let's
change gears
because we're running into some very
emotionally distressing things that she
couldn't articulate at that point
and in order to get through those we i
wanted to protect her so that's when we
slid over into the
the ketamine room and now she's
she's about she's in process and she's i
don't you could just see the light in
her eyes
now she's you know it's like she it's
like
it's not just like go get ketamine it's
like why are you here right
and and that's why we we talk about
what's going on and
well there was an experience one i had
an experience at one point where i felt
like i ended up like in a corner of the
world kind of
it was kind of like i felt like you ever
been in like a video game and you get
stuck somewhere on it you can't even
move like your
guy gets stuck i felt like i got stuck
at like the edge of the universe like
where the universe
like we like i finally found like the
two walls of the universe like the ends
of it
and i got stuck like in the corner
and i don't know what was going on were
you leaving the chair or coming back to
the chair i was on my way back to the
chair
okay yeah it's interesting like
you know because like did you feel like
you were like getting light in the chair
and then like your fingers started to
get all yeah you know i don't even
notice that i just remember
kind of talking in a conversation and
then next you know i go on this ride
and i'm not even talking that much
anymore i'm just kind of on this journey
people are so i talk to my patients a
lot and they
some of them remember some of them don't
but
um they come in different they come in
different like
personalities like you can kind of
there's i'm starting to get a
there's different types that come in
there like i got my musicians
and they start singing for me and uh you
know they're belting it out or they're
composing
right there in front of me and i'm like
this is cool and then you know you got
the guys who might my trees are running
off the screen
and my one kid who tried to hop up and
run out but he forgot he was on ketamine
and you can't move
he didn't even get out of the chair you
could just see it he was like and i was
like
it's okay man and uh that's crisped out
man he's probably all crisped out
yeah he he had some issues it gets i
mean it's definitely gnarly i was
i i didn't feel like i guess in some
ways it felt like a drug it felt like an
experience to me right you know um
i felt like i was kind of grateful for
the experience i was grateful to be back
from the experience whenever i got back
from the like trip or whatever you kind
of go on during it or whatever like
the visual the experience the
out-of-body kind of experience i felt
grateful whenever i got back to my chair
because there was moments where i was
like i am never
you know i don't care yeah they'll
i'll never they'll never find me yeah
it's like i'm lost like where am i
in the world in the universe that will
never find me i was at like i was in
atlanta i was in castlevania that video
game for when i was a kid
i was in some i was on the back of
someone's
neck i was a there was a lot it was i
was sliding down stuff a lot of like
moving along huge
i don't know if it was like electronic
land sides of
walls i had a lady recently
she could hear um i got like these
pictures of
a forest or in my one of my rooms and
she could hear the forest
wow and then she was like then she'd
hear a lot more like and i was like
that's pretty cool
you know because she it was she was not
disturbed she was just like oh yeah i
can hear the forest
and i was like that was a first like the
auditoriums were
are not as common that's strong is there
a reason why do we all need therapy now
what's going on have we got are we weak
people
do you think are we
you know it's funny because i'll talk
about therapy and stuff with my mother
and she doesn't
she doesn't not believe in it but she's
just like you just keep moving on you
know you keep going she's
more of like you tough it out type of
vibe and i come from more of like a
well why well what's going on like that
kind of type of vibe you know
i think you think it's an american pro
like not problem do you think it's like
a i think it's a
there's like a
there's a couple things resiliency okay
people
people don't bounce back um
um very as well as they think they do
um and the other thing is is like
how how old you are
and how like i'm sorry
young and having problems happen to you
when you're young
is very problematic
and because if you look at like say
you're writing a program
okay i got a coder here in nashville
actually
um you're writing a program okay the
earliest code you're writing
okay is sort of goes through everything
okay so when you're when you're a child
that's your earliest programming so that
tends to resonate
through your life and if you're not
being shaped with sort of like a good
societal
structure good parenting structure you
know they talk about keeping people out
of the system
or once they're in the system the system
doesn't work okay well how did they get
in the system
right so where do we where do we
set the boundaries from the get-go you
know
they used to have tv shows like leave it
to beaver and
things like that it was like sort of
like showing you how people are supposed
to behave
and and andy griffith show they were
very
like structured on this sort of
false reality of how people are supposed
to conduct themselves but it was very
civilized it wasn't dysfunctional
it was based on like love authority
respect
um and things like that and then as you
sort of everybody does their own thing
now
well they sort of do their own thing and
everything and so
the the the underpinnings of youth have
sort of
gotten more flexible but that also means
that their emotions are also more
flexible in all directions
does that make sense at the end part
doesn't
i don't know like i mean it i mean i
know it it probably should i just don't
know
if i was different person i would
understand it i bet like i
the way i grew up is like you you do x y
z
right and you chug through right and and
you everything was supposed to be fine
but as as we've moved forward as a
society like
my parents and and a lot of people's
parents they had jobs where they had
pensions and they had
they had more stability right and it's
less stable
now you have you have more flexibility
but with more flexibility comes more
uncertainty ah yeah so so people are
like more questions
people are feeling less secure in the
world
in reality they're probably more secure
right but they don't
feel that way and like after 2020
you know 2020 is like a rubber band
you know the suicide rate actually came
down okay
well what's gonna happen right i don't
know because i have people showing up in
my office now that are like
they're beginning to cope with what
happened to them in 2020
and you know yeah that's why we're here
yeah it's interesting man i mean uh you
know
i had like during the pandemic i had
like five friends that overdosed and
died like that just because they
couldn't get to recovery meetings i
think i think
it's they've never said that they're
dead but they
i you know i believe if they still had
opportunity to get to meetings which
were closed
um it would have just been helpful to
some of them you know
um just to still have the ability to go
like once you lose that connection you
start to isolate more than so much stuff
happens
you get stuck in your own world um and
yeah i think some of that too i think we
also were at a time where there's just
so much technology now we get such a
quick
reflections of us that are like just out
in the world that aren't
that aren't like rooted in ourselves um
i think that that can be very unnerving
to people the um
the you know i share
with patients i'm like you know being
connect being connected the feeling of
being connected it's not the icing on
the cake
it is the cake and you see that um
we're we're an incredibly disconnected
society
you go into any city and nobody knows
anybody
yeah even though they're living next to
a million people and if
and and you can look at the history of
like earth
you know you go to these blue zones
where people live unusually long
right okay you go to like okinawa costa
rica um
like i think it's sardinia croatia these
these places are not terribly affluent
but people are like really happy and
they live a really long time and they're
like why
and you know a big chunk of it is they
they have this thing with community like
they're all connected they're all
part of they're together and so when you
what's the
the opposite end of that is everybody's
alone and when you're isolated
bad things happen yeah and i think
that's one of the things that happens to
our brain our brain is a
he is literally a piece of machinery
that's
has the ability to connect with other
you have to people
yeah and it's like so when we take our
brain away from that and we're not doing
it of course our brain is going to get
sick
yeah you know it just makes sense it's
like a plant you know
um yeah it's not like a plant but it's
like something being connected is
is is crucial and you know
my our our family um
my wife's grandparents are still with us
so so they're
you know in their um 90s and
um and some of their brothers and
sisters are still with us and so
last year it was like awful because
these are people we would see every week
yeah and we i mean all the time we would
see and they'd show up to like
events and and then for like a year they
disappeared
yeah and like they'd stop and you'd wave
at them because you were so afraid to
you know because i worked i'm doing my
thing and and
i hadn't been vaccinated yet and so
everybody's living in fear
and everybody's isolating and you're
just like this is awful and then you see
that
you see that uh you know that do you see
that match.com commercial with the
satan dates 2020 you know a match made
in hell uh-uh that's the funniest thing
i honestly but it's it's a it's a a
great
sort of representation of how bad last
year was damn
yeah i believe in satan though but i
would like to see the commercial but
i'll probably see it
uh we can watch it later on um
any other questions that came up shown
there was one from a young lady that
came up you want to play that real quick
and then we'll get you
uh and then we can close it out we've
gone almost two hours hi sean
uh hour and a half hour and a half okay
cool cool
hi there my name is courtney um i
actually have
my first uh ketamine therapy appointment
scheduled for
next month and i've had some
prep appointments but i just wanted to
get your point of view as to
the potentials for how ketamine therapy
can
benefit people with complex
post-traumatic stress syndrome i know
there's a lot of information
um going around right now and i am just
really
interested to hear your thoughts on it
thank you so much
ganging thanks courtney and we may have
answered that really didn't we
maybe not um i cannot i can answer it
okay in a way um so
ketamine therapy is
i think the a a more
genuine or credible way to to
look at what ketamine therapy does is it
allows you access
to healing to to reconnecting with
yourself from seeing pain that you have
in a different way like at a more like
ethereal way right so so a diagnosis
um is not really a description
that is is what we're trying to do why
the diagnosis
is is a better way to look at what we're
trying to
approach and like i have people who kind
of had very bad things happen to them
and so so i want them to be able to
reconnect to that part of them that's
stuck in there
and if and if that if that part of their
emotional
baggage that's sort of pinned to that
moment
if they can connect to it and grieve and
get that that release
that emotional release of connection
then
they can begin to feel better and it's
not like we're checking off like
anxiety check ptsd check it's more like
what's what's you know what why are you
hurting so much
and and how does that show up in your
life because you can take somebody who's
struggling with something and
somebody will have insomnia and you
could take somebody who's struggling
with something
and they'll have depression and so it's
like what what really is the distress
what really is the root of their pain as
opposed to like a diagnosis
and it's more fundamental it gets back
to what's wrong
yeah you know as i'm hearing you say
that i i i i felt like
sometimes when i'm in therapy it's hard
sometimes it's like if my mood is
isn't that great that day i won't even
want to talk to my therapist i don't
want to share with them
sometimes i want to be like you know i
want to be
kind of i don't know sometimes i won't
really be in the mood
um sometimes i'll keep information from
them because i'm scared to share it or
because i don't feel comfortable
right you know but this kind of i felt
like this kind of takes away
some of that for me anyway took away
some of that
my own thoughts my own [ __ ] whatever
i'm attaching to whatever is
bothering me in my life and let me kind
of just
see what was bothering me yeah a little
protection
yeah it just kind of like it didn't even
it just
it felt like i was just there to get
some help it was like
it was almost like going in for like a
deep deep deeper deal
yeah your all your normal defense
mechanisms are sort of taking a break
yeah and you can be more genuine with
your emotional state
and and in that state you can be like
what really hurts versus what if i
convince myself
as my problem versus what is really
bouncing around in the back that i don't
want to look at
and and it's just it's it's a
yeah it's a much more like rich
sort of conversation with yourself yeah
yeah man it was it was definitely it was
it was really interesting
you know i would like to get some more
tools so then i go when i go back
what are some tools you think that i
could use when i go back uh
to or what are tools that someone can
use when they go into
their ketamine therapy after they've you
know met with their therapist and stuff
like that
what are things that they you feel like
they can do to best get uh
the most effectiveness out of their
experience well
so a couple of things are is kind of
getting some information on where you
are
so what i what i like is uh i i want
patients to get a couple of labs because
i want some i want some pointers
i want i want some data to uh to show me
where they are
so i get them have them get a vitamin d
i have them get a high sensitivity crp
test crp is like a test for inflammation
i um i do some brief
questionnaires so we have this little
online thing
uh their little and and they get these
health questionnaires but it's like
it generates a number it's like how
distressed are you okay and then
we start sending that to them every week
or so so we want to see what we're doing
we want to see
the baselines where are we starting
because what are we doing
and so we get some data on the front end
and i get to know them on the front end
and then as you go into the ketamine
you sort of organize your
i think i mentioned that i got this big
thing of paper and and i want them to
like look at their life
because that's how you sort of want to
like where what are we doing
where are we going with it where do we
propose
that your distress is sort of seated
you know what happened right and so then
you kind of know where to
toggle it and what can they do
if they are if the patient is sort of
like how can they best help you and the
medicine
or the therapist and the medicine uh
usually it's it's um
just i gotta get to know them a little
bit so
so it's like i gotta i gotta know what
brought them to me
right like what really brought them to
me as opposed to a diagnosis
i see is there a state that they can be
in is there an attitude that they can
have or is there
absolutely so so we know now that um
a a predictor of failure
is resistance or the inability to accept
it
so if you're basically it's if if you're
not willing to let go into it
it's not going to work that well okay so
we know this it's actually
a study popped up i saw it a month ago i
can't remember
what it was but they actually have some
predictors now and
the resistance to the process is
is gonna keep it from working for you
okay
so if you're like i don't want to do
this i'm not ready to let go
i would get yourself into a better head
space first and that's why we like we
want to get them into a better head
space going into it like
i got to get them sleeping first if
you're not sleeping you can't do
anything so first thing i do is get
people sleeping
because then you can you got to be able
to sleep to do anything
and so i try to get my patients sleeping
first oh you do
i mean like when they come in so like i
i usually see my patients for a couple
of weeks
at least before they come in so i want
to get them sleeping on a regular
schedule oh sleeping on a regular
schedule i thought you might put them to
sleep when they get there no no no no
no i'm sorry like like so prep work is i
want to get their sort of their life
sort of
moderated to some degree so that the
process is far more useful
right unless they're in like really bad
shape and then you just do it because
it's
it's harm reduction that's a different
category
yeah my account dude i had to go to a
comedy show one night after and that was
pretty
good it was okay man i mean it was
pretty good honestly
but it wasn't top-notch
you know i just felt a little glitchy i
had a
i was i don't know i felt like i was
about two centimeters off of my
regular skin and and i'm in this uh i'm
in this uh
fellowship of people out of um the
integrative psychiatry
institute out of boulder and we had a
little
get-together like a zoom uh session and
there was uh one of the psychiatrists
she had just gotten back from surgery
on ketamine and she was like talking to
all of us and
we were like and it was it was
fascinating she was like fresh
and she had gotten like something done
to her and and were just sitting there
watching this i was like
wow and she was having like insights
about her relationship with her mother
wow and that went back like decades
and and you know it's it's
it's fascinating i mean you stick around
you just hang out in the
in the in the areas where people are
doing this and you can really you kind
of get an idea of
what this is doing to people it's just
the insights
and the perceptions and the healing that
that are
sort of swimming around in this whole
thing
um it's not covered by a lot of
insurances right
not yet not yet so so it depends on
where you are you know
where i am not so much um but
my understanding is if you kind of like
the further west you go
the insurers are you know more friendly
to it
however interestingly because of 2020
mental health is actually getting
um much more
um it's been considered much more
important historically
in in sort of all the industries and
and so that is good because a it's long
overdue
b it means that people can
really get access to
kind of healing as opposed to limping
and and it's sort of like it's the hope
of
yeah everybody who's in this is that
when you have somebody who's been
harmed in a way that they
are not able to interact with the world
in a way that is peaceful
you want to do everything you can in a
way that is
safe and sort of research based
to get them on the road again yeah why
not well i'm sure that 30 years ago or
whenever there was a conversation
between two people about like uh
antidepressants that was just like this
possibly you know it's like you never
know like something new is always coming
along new things are always coming along
and
we're always evolving and stuff in
different spaces and yeah i'm certainly
curious i love the idea of
actually trying to find some healing as
opposed to
uh getting a crutch every day you know
um because that starts to be ridiculous
when i think of that every day i have to
take a pill when right when i get up
just that my mind has to even think
about that
instead of being able to be in this free
space where it can just wake up
yeah like it's kind of crazy to me you
know it almost wonders
how much of a hitch in my vibe
is that overall just that my brain knows
right when it gets up that i it has to
remind me to go take a pill it's like
it's kind of weird you know it's kind of
feels very unhuman
um what what actually happens to your
brain to the parts in your brain during
the
ketamine therapy um so what what happens
there's a bunch of there's actually two
things that happen
um the
receptors get tagged that are
responsible for your like
anxiousness and depressive symptoms but
the other cool
little thing is is there's a triggering
cascade
uh from a it's called bdnf and what it
is
it helps your neurons like sort of
change like grow
little sprouts and and and the
synapses the little ends can sort of
become plastic
and make make changes to your your
nerves and they grow a little bit
and you can actually see it they've
they've imaged this you can you can
google it and find pictures of
dendritic sprouting or dendritic spines
that have been exposed to ketamine
and so that's like actual like
growth so if you think like
if you're growing things in your head
you know you can
do something with it that's that's like
that that cyborg stuff like you could
have a new garden
well you and you slide an electrode in
there and
and all of a sudden you can like grow
connections into different things and
you know you're going to have high def
out the rear in no time
on the back of your head you have a
backup camera yeah
i mean you think about it i mean
we didn't have cell phones 20 you know
we didn't have an iphone 20 years ago so
we're going to go to the moon um every
day in
10. i i would bet we're going to be
pretty augmented kids don't have any
problem wearing electronic gear on their
heads now
yeah so i don't know i have i have
neurons growing onto a chip out of my
ears
pretty soon it'll be hey it'd be pretty
freaky
look let me know how it goes yeah okay
i'll call you
i'll call you as long as you're the
guinea pig first man
uh i think that'll work out uh dr jason
pooler thank you so much for being here
with us today man you bet thank you
really appreciate it man
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling like these leaves i
must be
cornerstone
[Music]
but it's gonna take a little
time for me to set that parking brake
and let myself go
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy
[Music]
b